hello today i want to talk to you about
the t bioinfo platform a platform
designed for bioinformatics discovery
and it offers scalable and efficient
multi-omics workflows designed for
biologists and clinicians that want to
work with complex and large omics
datasets now the platform is flexible it
can be extended with various scripts and
r and python and it can easily be
extended through packages that we often
use for publication quality
visualization or even with interactive
dashboards so today i'll talk to you a
little bit more about the methods of
analysis integration mathematical
modeling and simulation as well as
visualization that you can use on the
tbi info platform
so the methods are designed to offer
consistent and easy to use workflows for
different types of omics data like
genomics transcriptomics and others and
the platform can be integrated into your
research lab workflow essentially
connecting to your local hosted servers
or deployed onto the cloud for various
aspects of the platform results like
visualization or results in a tabular
format it can also offer
tools for preparing mathematical
modeling and and therefore simulation of
various experimental factors
so the key feature of the platform is
really all about processing various
types of omics data and that includes
taking the data that comes from the lab
and processing genomic epigenomic
transcriptomic proteomic metagenomic
environment and many other types of
omics data and that's why the key focus
of this platform is to enable processing
analysis visualization and ultimately
multi-omics integration with easy
easy-to-use visual
and structural outputs
after extensively testing this platform
with many users we have discovered that
the significant features allow the
platform to be very user-friendly for
biologists and useful for even technical
bioinformaticians that find it extremely
or mostly useful
importantly the outputs are provided in
various formats that could later be used
for downstream analysis in commonly used
tools like python and r
and provide important features for
biologists that would like to just
explore their data or even perform
complex analysis that requires a lot of
resources like ram
or cpu or even gpu
various sections of the platform
could be useful for those that use
standard tools
and large data sets
and also could be adapted to specialized
data data that is developed within the
lab
specific formats of the data as well as
specific types of analyses and so we've
been privileged to work with many
researchers at both academic and
commercial institutions that have worked
with our team as well as the tower
bioinformatics research center to make
sure that these tools can also be
utilized across the whole lab and
reproducible for others to preview and
understand what the analysis results
mean
so as i mentioned the key feature are
tools for reproducible workflow
and that includes color-coded maps for
logical analysis
explanatory pop-ups that show what the
method actually does
it's a guided process that limits the
number of mistakes that one can make as
they build the pipeline and produces
some
interactive or visual outputs that are
easily interpreted for biologists
one commonly used data
is rna-seq or transcriptomic data so we
have a collection of tools to map and
quantify
gene expression
using various tools
like
mapping on the reference genome if it's
annotated generating a transcriptome
and identifying novel transcripts as
well as downstream analysis for
gene set enrichment analysis
differential gene expression and
all kinds of annotation especially for
model genomes
more recently there has been a lot of
interest in single cell rna sequencing
and so we've designed a series of
options for a typical workflow using the
serrat package where you can produce
standard visualization as well as
outputs with an rds file that you can
later on download and and search through
the different objects that were
developed as a part of this workflow
importantly it offers some standard
tools as well as annotation and complex
heat maps that could also be
revised in an interactive way
microbiome sequencing
using hyper variable region amplicon
sequencing data or whole 16s ribosomal
rna data
can be processed using tools like chime
2
data 2 using reference databases like
silva
and many other tools that could be
selected like phyloseq and this produces
static visualizations or a dashboard
that allows us to compare different
types of annotation in the metadata and
identify
taxonomic variation
alpha and beta diversity and explore
variation across
different types of samples or groups of
samples
another type of data that could be
analyzed on the platform is genomic data
where we can process fast q files for
variant calling
and finding differences between
frequencies of mutations as well as
analysis of multiple sequence alignment
with phylodynamics and even mapping of
those results onto protein structures
as data sets grow and become more
complex
researchers utilize more and more data
mining and machine learning methods to
make sense of what is in the data
understand the biological processes that
define variation across samples and
build machine learning predictive models
using different methods and different
sets of features like like biomarker
discovery
or gene set construction and so we've
designed a series of interactive tools
that could be used to
train and deploy these models
also using various features to
understand the source of variation
and the different types of optimal
settings to find those
variations ultimately when all of this
data is generated a lot of times one of
the greatest challenges is to integrate
this data and so because we work with
research institutions like the tauber
bioinformatics research center academic
research in this field
has
resulted in a series of novel approaches
in a series of novel approaches to be
able to map these complex networks of
omix features and find
association in these networks
for critical features
the platform is extendable and so we
have been working with a variety of labs
companies and individual users to make
sure that the outputs are interactive
and could assist the researchers in
finding patterns that are most
interesting to them and so we offer
visualization as a service as well as
custom solutions so that you can make
sense of complex data
we also offer extensive training
using
tools that biologists can use like the
tbi info platform but also
methods of coding and downstream
analysis in r and in python and we have
developed a full
website dedicated to such training
called omics logic so you can explore
the variety of
training courses as well as programs led
by mentors and exemplar projects that
you can
identify ways researchers use these
methods to analyze their own data
over the years
thousands of students from around the
world from us south america europe
middle east
asia
have gone through such training and
we've established relationships with
many universities around the world to
offer such curricula and train students
to utilize tools that they can rely on
to make sense of complex optics data